oh mate that is
that's the worst thing i've ever put in
my mouth
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we close out season 16 with tom
holland he began his career at 12 years
old in the west end production of billy
elliot now he's one of hollywood's
biggest box office draws from
award-winning performances in the
impossible to the marvel cinematic
universe and on the topic of the latter
he stars in what's sure to be one of the
year's biggest films spider-man no way
home which is set to release in theaters
on december 17th tom holland welcome to
the show hello mate thank you thank you
for having me
and before we begin one last time for
season 16 how are you a spicy food
what's going through your head as we
prepare to dig in i'm okay with spicy
food i mean at nando's i'm a medium or a
hot if i'm feeling adventurous extra hot
is too far gone for me so i think today
is gonna be
rather brutal and i think everyone will
get to see a side to me that no one has
ever seen before maybe i haven't even
seen this side to me that's about to
come out but i'm very excited i'm a huge
fan of the show it was actually my mate
twain
a couple years ago i was like you should
do this show called hot ones i said
what's hot ones he's like it's a show
where you eat spicy chicken wings and
you talk about stuff i was like
it sounds so stupid and then i watched
the first episode i watched idris elba
immediately was obsessed with your show
and have since then been a huge fan
[Music]
the classic hot sauce okay
[Music]
oh yeah other side other side other side
you just saved me
i went for the worst one the first wings
can you imagine can i say a huge thank
you because
that would have been we would have cut
this well sure
okay so we're going over here yep
all right
oh yeah that's nice
[Music]
wow i am getting a bit of a kick now
though
so spiderman no way home features the
return of alfred molina as dr octopus a
role that he had more than 15 years ago
which i imagine is a unique situation
for an actor can you recall an instance
of his mind being blown by the
technology and innovation that goes into
making spider-man movies today
that's got a delayed reaction
the old classic hot sauce there
um
obviously when he was making the film i
think it was 2002 maybe
his arms his sort of robotic arms were
puppets they were like real tangible
things and they'd have a guy on each one
and they would puppeteer them while he
was performing so he had to work in
tandem with the other four guys
on this film obviously technology has
advanced cgi has become so
you know prevalent in these films so it
was amazing seeing him have a bit more
freedom on set with the way he could
move without having to rely on other
people we had this thing called a
toothpick rig
which is like a long
bar
like almost like a crane with a platform
on one end and weights on the other and
they put him on that crane so they can
move him around
so that it looks like the arms are
carrying him and he loved it like he
absolutely loved it but the funny thing
is is that you'd be talking to him and
he'd be attached to the rig and because
he has no control over where he goes
he'd be talking to you he'd be like yeah
so tom i'm from south london and then he
would just suddenly like disappear and
he was like oh [ __ ] hell mate i'll
see you later
so it was a it was a pleasant a pr a
plevage sorry the spices joy is i've got
still chicken in my teeth right oh and
it comes i know that i know that all too
well there's lots of times i'm putting
up a front like it's not bothering me
but
every episode every episode but it um it
was a pro it was a privilege to get to
work with them with alfred he was a good
guy i really liked working with him
[Music]
it's very sweet
that was really nice i actually really
like that one it was quite sweet i
didn't really get any vinegar but it was
nice i liked it the next one looks
nasty
it's very red chicken's not supposed to
be red like that
okay so i was interested to read that
spider-man no way home director john
watts actually assigned a john hughes
movie marathon which you hosted at your
atlanta home yes and i'm curious if you
think there's any common dna between the
spider-man franchise that you star in
and then these classic coming-of-age
teen movies from the 1980s there
definitely is
jon definitely took uh inspiration from
those movies there are aspects of the
way characters are
dressed or the way they look that is
definitely um inspired by
it by those movies um
and i think that is what sets our
franchise apart from the rest of the
kind of
superhero genre is that they have this
kind of really happy-go-lucky teenage
coming-of-age high school movie vibe
which i've never really seen before in a
superhero film ferris bueller's day off
for me was the one
that had the most inspiration for
spider-man this kid who's kind of
breaking the rules but he kind of is
doing it for the right reasons but the
biggest inspiration for me
and my biggest goal in playing
spider-man
was
i really wanted to be this generation's
marty mcfly yeah i love that that's up
for everyone else's opinion but for me
i'm really proud of what we did and
especially my relationship between me
and downey to me there's a lot of
similarities between marty and doc and i
know that they have deep faked us and
made that happen which actually was a
huge honor for me i loved seeing it uh
but um but yeah so that for me would
have been the biggest inspiration
[Music]
i'm feeling good i'm feeling good you
look good thank you mate
that's nice
kind of like a barbecue sauce yeah with
like a little kick to it
yeah that was that's good i like that
one
so your career it's taken you around the
world and i've read that you like to
visit golf courses in each new city that
you visit i played baseball my whole
life but i think the muscle memory of
swinging a bat has ruined any potential
i'll ever have of being good at golf do
you have any general swing tips for just
hopeless duffers like myself
[Music]
uh i mean
short on your backswing is what i'd say
because the golf clubs now the
technology is so advanced that you don't
have to hit it that hard for the ball to
go that far a distance so shorten your
backswing and don't try and hit it too
hard
well i'm taking notes they're down i'll
climb to the course next time i go are
you ready to move on here to the next
wing los calientes verde and you're
doing great los calientes verde
okay
this one looks like it's gonna surprise
me it's got a bit of a green hue in
there it does it's got a green heel
all right so immediately spicy this one
[ __ ]
i'm gonna go for a second hit though but
you're going back in
because it's really nice
salute
okay
wow
wow
this is such a good idea for an
interview
because my brain
my brain is all over the place we've got
anything we've got them and i would be
so honest
so you had an interesting line on the
nerdist podcast where you talked about
how playing a superhero kind of takes
away your biggest super power as an
actor since you're also covering your
face
what do you see as the limitations or
maybe even the opportunities for an
actor when you do spend half a movie in
behind a costume
i mean
it comes with its own set of challenges
for sure
[ __ ] me
wow
i want to try and do this and not have
any milk okay we'll see how that i don't
think that's gonna yeah there's no we're
not even we're only four in
it's definitely difficult i mean as an
actor you use expression with your face
to convey emotion and when you take that
away you have to figure out how to do it
with your physicality so if you took off
the spider-man suit and i behaved the
way i would while in the suit you'd
think i was a crazy person and acting
way way too much and too big but cover
up your face all of a sudden those
bigger reactions feel normal
my secret weapon is that i
will always pretend like my arms are
dead
so that when i move my arms kind of
swing around so peter parker's hands are
always doing the most crazy stuff and
for me that has been a really good way
of like
making him feel youthful while also in
moments of peril and and stuff like that
um but it's also sometimes a great thing
like if i've gone out the night before
and had a little bit too much to drink
if i've got a mask on no one knows so
it's fine
[Music]
i'm supposed to be going to a lakers
game tonight i'm gonna have to go [ __ ]
after every quarter
let's do this
revolutionary
this one's a little
[Music]
one's good that is revolutionary yeah
[ __ ] who as advertised
wow
wow
all right tom we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
graham where we do a deep dive on our
guest instagram podcast interesting
pictures that need more context so we'll
show you the picture over here on the
map
a fellow season 16 hot ones alum right
there right i love him so much he's one
of the greatest guys i've ever met i
remember doing a scene with him i told
this story yesterday actually
and i said to him sometimes as an actor
if you're doing a scene
that requires like
real stress i find it quite helpful if
someone kind of roughs me up a little
bit
and i said to john i was like listen
before the scene could you just rough me
up a bit
and uh you know just just scare me a
little bit please and he was like nah
man i don't want to do that like you're
my little brother i love you man i don't
want to do that
okay
i appreciate that if you don't want to
do that that's fine and they went right
rolling and they went action and he went
and i was like oh my god and it was
great and it worked so well for the
scene but he just
he just didn't want me to know it was
coming
but he probably cracked me one
i look back on that as a very fond
experience and meeting him was you know
one of the highlights we haven't had the
chance to work together since but i
would love to
oh my god
it just came back yeah
they can they can sometimes when you
least expect it but like from deep
within
this looks really nice i can't wait to
try it
okay i'm just gonna eat it ready ready
oh no
oh no
oh not bad
at first
at first
oh come on yeah yeah
it starts to grow on you a little bit so
interesting in it how it hits you like
wow
that's amazing
[Music]
sometimes i really try to figure out how
to make my voice sound
cooler if i'm doing scenes i just need
to eat [ __ ] spicy we figured out a
technique here today wow
okay
i'm gonna go for a second hit because i
want to okay then i'm going back to see
how that okay
i feel like i'm really seeing the
actor's side of you you know like really
immersing yourself in the experience i
really want to see what this is about
way worse the second time
wow
well
[Music]
it's in my nose now
[Music]
so i know that while you're weary of
overly laddish behavior that the pub
culture the old school pub culture it
still has a special place in your heart
and then pub food to me it's an endless
topic of fascination whenever we visit
london right can you explain what a
carvery is for the uninitiated oh a
cavalry right a cavalry is
firstly amazing it is a portion of food
that normally
revolves around a piece of meat it can
be any meat
i don't know if this is an actual rule
but i know that my local pub used to do
it when we were kids but if you're 16 so
two years under the legal drinking age
if you have a carvery they are allowed
to serve you a pint of beer
i guess the idea is is that the amount
of food cancels out the beer
obviously as kids we would abuse that
rule and go and
not eat the food and just drink a beer
but a carvery is like a portion of meat
with food like a roast dinner what does
it mean if a dish's mingi ming means
it's disgusting like that last wing was
ming hin
well if you thought that was me
we'll see what you think about the next
one the milk looks so good
wow
oh yeah
that's it that's not that bad
wow that one's not bad i like that one
yeah it's tasty
it's the second hit it's yes i think
it's when you go back in
listen i didn't come in to play
i can prepare to eat these chicken wings
so there's a lot of lore surrounding
that 10 minute long tsunami scene that
opens up the impossible your feature
film debut yeah is it true that you guys
only had one shot of doing that because
to rebuild the set and shoot it again
would have blown the budget yes
oh my gosh
essentially what they did is they built
[Music]
they built um like a
oh man my lips are
oh
they built a set that was a third of the
size of the actual hotel in which it
happened
the the
they had something like three million
litres of water in a huge tank with
these
breakaway doors
and essentially the director had this
big red button
i think they were using something like
14 cameras at the same time all set in
specific locations there was obviously
no one
on set while this was happening because
it was very dangerous
oh my god
then they hit the button
and the water came out and destroyed the
set and it was incredibly impressive to
witness it looks great in the film and
then obviously what they do is they
upscale it so the third size model then
looks full size and then they put us in
they compass in
and it was amazing it was really
incredible
and um and that's that's the end of my
story
and [ __ ] me that is so spicy
is it true that you blew a star wars
audition because you couldn't contain
your laughter reading lines opposites
someone pretending to be a droid yeah
yeah that's that's very true i don't
think that's the reason why i didn't get
the role i think john boyega was just
better for the role than me um but i
just remember
thinking
there's no way this lady is going to
read
the robot's lines opposite me just
because
that would be ridiculous
and
i don't remember what my line was but it
was let's get back to the falcon
and then this lady bless her would sit
there with full commitment and she just
was like
[Laughter]
and i just remember thinking the first
time she did it i went ah that's funny
oh wow all right brilliant we'll do it
again we'll do it again sorry
did the line again
i remember sort of saying like you're
not actually going to do that right
she was like well yeah the robot's part
of the scene is the character it's
r2d2 or c3p i don't know
yeah i just got the giggles because you
know when you realize you've got
something so wrong yeah i just couldn't
stop laughing
i'm not going to try the lemon because i
want to i want to do the whole
experience i want to and then at the end
when we cut the cameras i'm going to
drink more cream so quickly we're going
to bring in a whole other game i'm gonna
drink it so quickly you have no idea
[Music]
let's do it the bomb
all right ready yeah let's do
it oh i've gone for the bone oh wow oh
yeah oh no i didn't even put it in my
mouth
whoa
victoria just went like this oh no
oh mate
oh mate
that is so bad
you and me same page there
do you finger lick or do you at this
stage
i just survived oh my god at this stage
i just survived
oh my gosh
yeah yeah
i think it's dry time to try this lemon
trick
if this is a joke and this is gonna make
it worse we're not setting you up not
setting you up i don't know if it'll
help that much
that doesn't help
i don't think i don't think anything
will i don't think anything will
oh man
i have to walk this off for a second
yeah yeah take a lap take a lap we've
seen some laughs on this show
huh
taught a magnum
yeah we'd love a magnum
you don't have any magnum
oh mate that is
that's the worst thing i've ever put in
my mouth
wow i feel so sick you okay i'm
fantastic man i'm having the time of my
life
i feel like i just got like botox but
had no
anesthesia or something not that i've
ever had botox i don't know what it
feels like
that's where the whole world's like he's
had botox
[Laughter]
could i please have some warmth yeah
we're on it we're on it we're on it
coming through so much i can give you a
hug i see you
we got a secret dom is always here okay
thank you
i appreciate it
so tell me
paul rudd's episode yeah yeah our
favorite episode oh that's
uh know why yeah look at us look at us
look at us who would have thought
who would have thought like [ __ ]
me
this one is up to 12 meaning that you
should be 12 and above or 12. i think on
a scale from 1 to 10
[Music]
oh mate i'm so stupid
[Laughter]
for people under the age of 12.
[Applause]
okay
oh wow i feel
cold
and on fire at the same time like my
insides feel like they're burning
but my outsides feel like it's really
cold
oh i don't want to do
this all right we're ready i'm ready
let's go
[Music]
i've got a lot of that on my lip there
oh yeah
i'm a second dip there because i don't
think i got it are you sure yeah i'm a
second dip because that are you sure
yeah we're going all right
[Music]
oh yeah our spicy man
oh wow
oh yeah wow okay
so i'm always amused when i hear you say
that people confuse you from one of
those british actors with classic
training remarking
you wanna only to two percent of drama
school classes what do you think an
actor learns just going directly into
the industry talking to directors being
on set that maybe they wouldn't pick up
if they went to a prestigious drama
school like rada
um
i think that sometimes
uh a benefit
of not going to drama school
is going in
fresh
and allowing your teachers to be
the director you know
and this is a piece of advice i got from
robert downey actually to let my body do
the work rather than thinking about
everything so for me
i tend to learn my lines the morning of
so that the moment i'm saying them
they're as fresh as possible
and uh is that doctor here
because the [ __ ]
wow
i'm not joking no i'm joking okay
he's a good actor he's a good actor
this might be the best milk
right i've ever had like an oasis like
you've been walking through the desert
that's exactly what it feels like right
the last one on the list
apollo
[Music]
the last dab
with the apollo pepper
[Music]
okay all right let's do this last app
but i have to say you know whoa that's
too much is it
listen
i've committed now
it's there
it's very that looks like
maybe maybe hit that with a little
no i've done it
okay
i feel like i'm about to jump off a
cliff or something
that's a lot as well i put weight you've
got a tiny bit on there
you're showing your experience i know
but you know what i got to join the
party this is the season 16. yours wow
this is the season 16 finale
the season 16 finale and tom you've been
so brave coming into this not sure how
it's gonna go and look at you
drenching sauces going in for double
hits
all right let's do this all right it's
been a pleasure mate i've really enjoyed
this pleasure is all mine
[Music]
i got oh no
[Music]
i hate my job
[Laughter]
oh mate
i know but tom the good thing is you've
slayed the spicy sauce beast we have put
the nail in the coffin of season 16.
and if we've learned anything through
this interview it's that you love movies
and that you love making movies and i've
heard that you have a propensity to
maybe take a souvenir or two from set
and so to close things out i just want
to ask you of all of those souvenirs
that you've taken from movie sets over
the years what is your holy grail the
one that has the most sentimental value
[Music]
[Music]
next time i do a crying scene
i'm calling you
and you gotta send me this hot sauce i
will show up on set i'll show up on set
my favorite souvenir was actually given
to me
that wasn't given to me was given to my
little brother patty
when black panther was coming out
robert downey jr was making look to do
little in london
and he was staying down the road from
where i live
and he invited us
to a screening of a black panther
at his house
and paddy comes running into the room
and he's holding the original iron man
helmet and downey had given it to him as
a gift
that's a really special one for me
because
i was lucky enough to join the mcu but i
joined it very late
and that souvenir you know that's from
the original film that's the birthplace
of this incredible world that
kevin feige and marvel have created you
know and downey and favreau kick-started
so to have something from that film is a
huge honor
a holy grail and look at you tom holland
putting a bow on season 16 taking on the
wings of death and living to tell the
tale and now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you tom
holland this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life
spiderman home is coming out
december 17th
it's the best part of my movie that's
ever been made
it's so fun and exciting
it's emotional
it's heartfelt
i've been so it's such an honor for me
to play spider-man for all this time and
for it to come to this point honestly he
means the world to me
i'm going to be sick
so i'm going to sign off
it's been a pleasure thank you so much
[Applause]
please feel free to roll on this yeah
it's the bomb
wow
god jack you took a big old bite there
me
are you good with spicy food
don't mind it that's hot
you're the coolest person i've ever met
jack's just gone that's hot though
yeah you just have the glass i love the
jug
i'm getting on you are there bro
how are you feeling
water makes it worse as well you don't
want you need that milk where's the knot
oh i think i'm gonna [ __ ] my pants
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans and there are many
reasons to be a monthly hot one
subscription box subscriber but if you
ask me at the top of that list is the
fact that you get to try things first
before anybody and that's what's
happening in december because in the
december subscription box for the first
time ever
hot sauce for kids that's right hot
sauce for kids i'd like to introduce you
to hot ones junior the green
this sauce is a super tasty flavor clash
of green apple sweet banana warm
jalapeno lets kids sort of experience
the hot ones tradition but at the
foothills of mount scoville it's perfect
for french fries chicken nuggets the
things that kids love get your hands on
hot ones junior be the first to try it
in the december subscription box
heatness.com.com to get your hands on
the green hot ones junior before anyone
else
it's super tasty and it's a hot sauce
for kids
[Music]
you